what's going on guys I'm Hal Rudnick so
fandom went ahead and gathered the top
100 most searched for villains that most
intrigued fans in 2018 they span across
400,000 plus
movies TV shows anime and video game
communities if you want to see that list
you can check it out at fandom comm or
check it out in the description below
and this list it inspired us and we
decided to compile our top 5 villains in
TV and movies in 2018 and we have an
awesome panel to talk about it with
first off she is the editor-in-chief of
SJ news
what's up Roth Cornett what's up how you
know him from honest trailers he is the
reigning movie fights champion of the
world
dan Morelle what's going on Dan how you
doing how oh pretty good pretty good
ready to talk some villains oh they're
the fun parts to play yes speaking of
fun parts this guy has all sorts of fun
parts and things and writes funny things
you know from honest trailers and he's
just a delightful young man Joestar me
and all my parts are here to talk about
villain you know there are a lot to
choose from in 2018 but we narrowed it
down to a top five we're gonna take this
list from five all the way down to one
let's go with the number five that we
all settled on Jimmy McGill from better
call Saul you're on your own I am done
you know for one thing I like the lackey
villain he is destined to become
I'm also drawn to the idea of the Joker
saying all it takes is one bad day and
for Jimmy McGill it's taken just a
series of bad days the amazing thing for
me just about the show in general is
that it shouldn't have worked on every
level
you know prequels rarely work this was a
character that was in effect he when we
met him he it was a he was a murderer
you know and he at will not himself but
he's certainly advocated for it men had
no problem with it as much as you are
rooting against him by the end of this
season because he becomes a untenable
human being you still have so much and
that you get how he got there that's
kind of an amazing achievement all right
coming in at number
for the kingpin the big man on campus
from daredevil and so is it that double
shot that got him onto the list I think
that might have put him over the top
being in two very well-received projects
in the same year certainly doesn't hurt
yeah but the kingpin is a character into
the spine into the spider verse you know
he doesn't have kind of the screen time
that he doesn't daredevil so you don't
have the time to get to know him but
even in the small amount of time that he
is there he is equally menacing and
again he as in daredevil you you
empathize with him because his motive is
one that feels very human yeah and I
think that that's kind of a theme
particularly this year with our villains
are some of them are just scary people
but some of them are you're scared
because you do understand why they do
what they do it's very scary to be
watching somebody doing objectively bad
things and but say like well if I were
in that situation might I do maybe
that's what I would do to I think you
know he's great in spider-verse but even
without the ones who punch
I think kingpins role in daredevil
season 3 still cements him in this list
number three this is a little bit of an
unusual interesting choice the bear from
annihilation annihilation bear hell yeah
this bear is one of the most haunting
images I've seen on screen in years it's
heartbreaking it's terrifying it's
monstrous yeah look at it's nothing to
look at listen to
that movie has incredible visuals
incredible sound design and visual
effects that is the scene that I regret
that people largely we're not it was
able to see in a theatre it was not
released in theaters in most places
worldwide that scene in a theater in the
dark on the screen just the way that the
design of that creature worked the sound
design the visual of it the tension in
that scene was for me one of the most
unforgettable movie moments of the year
and even though I was like them that was
like two minutes in the movie yes but it
was a an incredible two minutes yeah
something strikes a chord if you walk
away thinking about it it's yet it's
done something it's the scene that I
think of when I think of that movie yeah
big year for the Black Panther and the
Black Panther villain kill monger our
number two villain of the year
I want the plow there's a theme here
which is that every single one of these
villains is one that you you can you can
empathize with you can understand their
point of view you can see a circumstance
in which you would have that point of
view and you a lot of times you just
edge up to the point of sort of agreeing
with the perspective up until the point
that the perspective the answer to that
perspective is lots of death and murder
I think I think a lot of people when we
talk about kill monger right that
statement office
oh yeah we're just all gonna agree with
kill monger and it's not about agreeing
with them it's about a villain having an
incredibly strong point of view
especially for a comic book movie beyond
like I must destroy the Avengers by
dropping an island on them yes sky beam
the Avengers or what it's you get you
knew what this guy wanted you knew why
he wanted it it makes sense exactly for
him if yeah exactly
for him it's logic and that's the point
if you're not seeing and nobody's saying
yes that's the right answer tracks well
it's because Ryan Coogler brought such a
sense of grounding to that movie it's
not the same as Ronan or you know
whoever saying like I'm going to bathe
the galaxy and Kree blood for what they
did to Xander it's like you know like
you get what
happened but you're not you're just okay
whatever fine like the fact that they
brought into this comic book film they
wove actual societal issues into it it's
about two billion people all over the
world it looks like us but their lives
are a lot harder
what Conda has the tools that liberate
them all a lot of people's like well it
still just ends in a big cartoon fight
and yes it does but I think to minimize
the entire villain of come on gar by
just saying that it ends in the same CGI
fight that a lot of movies that other
combat movies do that's to dismiss
everything that comes before that which
i think is really really well done so
we're at number one but before we do
number one let's give a shout out to
some of the honorable mentions some of
the villains that were oh so villainous
but didn't quite make our top five list
so Roth would you like to uh sure
there's a television show that Spencer
and I both stump for quite a bit that we
hope everybody will get on board with
and that is killing Eve the villain is
villanelle there's lust and attraction
and sociopathy all merge into one I'm
gonna kill me and it's just sexy and
psychologically disturbing and thrilling
all at once
damn yes what do you like to quick hit
there's one please from another actor
from the MCU but not in the MC in an MCU
movie Chris Hemsworth as Billy Lee and
bad times he's one of those villains
that comes in at the end and just
totally takes over the movie and then
one that I know Roth and I are both on
board for Peyman the demon yeah
hereditary the trickster oh my god I
love that movie so much and and not
knowing what's happening for the whole
movie but you this entity that just
permeates everyone and everything in
that film
Joestar
there's something that didn't make this
list that you feel pretty good about
yeah so it might just be the pro
wrestling fan in me but one of the most
important things about a villain to me
is how bad do I want to see them get
punched in the face oh yeah so many
times and the villain that that did that
for me this year was in season three of
the last Kingdom on Netflix I implore
you after you're done watching killing
Eve make sure you watch the last Kingdom
this guy at the walled in the last
Kingdom he's the son of the king he was
passed over for the throne he's
constantly just you know conniving and
complaining and bitching and moaning in
season 3 is the season where he finally
sort of tries to make his move I am the
son of the king do your duty it's a hard
line to walk the line between I want to
punch you and it's starting to turn me
off because I don't want you on camera
anymore and he walks that fine line
beautifully totally worth checking out
on that I think it's time to reveal our
number one on this list and when I snap
my fingers would you all please say who
it is yeah there was a lot of buildup to
Thanos in the MCU and I think we got a
pretty satisfying dose of them in
infinity war I never told you to lie
that's why you're so bad at it like all
of these other villains though we don't
agree with him there is a logic to his
motivations that isn't just I like power
because I like tower right and he's he
actually does all of these things that
were taught are cliche like they
literally monologues he stops in the
third act and gives a monologue about
why he's doing what it but you buy it
because Josh Brolin's performance is
really good yes
visual effects of incredible are really
good that they tell the story in a
really good way and is there anything
more homicidal than literally killing
half of the universe and yet they
constructed it in such a way that you're
like yeah actually why he's doing there
yeah yeah yeah he's a pretty cool guy
it's also the final I hope it is the
exclamation point on this trope in
cinema where we see the
constant trope or in the recent years of
I have to kill all of these people to
save the environment which I think the
first 15 times was like oh it gives me
pause
but the snap is it yeah that's good you
know that's the period and the
exclamation point on that sentence I
work in that true yeah you've done it as
much as you as big as you can do it on a
larger sales you can do it so I think
we're done
another thing about Thanos is how maybe
it's just the pro wrestling fan in me
sure Joe but villains villains and
wrestling have our if your villain gets
too cool then they stop being a villain
and now they're just like a cool like
screw you Authority Thanos is cool like
Thanos is really really really cool it's
the performance it's the direction it's
the writing he never makes that full
turn of like oh that guy's too cool to
be a bad guy right like that's it's a
great balance that they strike with them
you guys what an epic list
yeah Joestar Dan Merle Roth Cornett
thank you for sharing your thoughts and
opinions with everybody what did you
think of this list agree disagree who
was left off that needed to be on there
and who was your number one rocketing
all the way to the top at 2018 let us
know in the comments section we want to
know I want to thank my guests again I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies go to fandom comm check out
their list and we'll see you next time
bye bye
[Music]